[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo un nuevo caso de brutalidad
policial que se ha comparado con el del
afroamericano george roy tiene américa
latina' conmocionada justicia para
victoria reclama un movimiento en línea
por la muerte de una ciudadana
salvadoreña a manos de cuatro agentes
mexicanos en tulum el hecho también
trabajo con más fuerza la indignación de
mujeres que piden que se detengan los
feminicidios empezamos
el pasado 27 de marzo una mujer
salvadoreña identificada como victoria
salazar murió en la ciudad turística de
tulum en mexico mientras era sometida
por la policía de acuerdo con las
autoridades victoria fue detenida por
alterar el orden público pero los vídeos
de los momentos previos a su arresto
revelan que la mujer no agredió a nadie
una serie de grabaciones que le dieron
la vuelta al mundo dejaron ver como
victoria era esposada contra el suelo
mientras una mujer policía le ponía su
rodilla en la espalda y como su cuerpo
era ha subido a una patrulla la fiscalía
del estado de quintana roo confirmó que
victoria falleció por una fractura en la
parte superior de la columna vertebral
los cuatro agentes fueron detenidos para
ser procesados por feminicidio y por
ello podrían enfrentarse hasta 50 años
de prisión victoria trabajaba en el área
de limpieza de un hotel era madre de dos
hijas había huido de la violencia y la
falta de oportunidades en el salvador
llegó a mexico en 2016 y en 2018 obtuvo
la residencia por razones humanitarias
no la llevaron a ningún lado y
precisamente este es un punto muy
importante para que nosotros pudiéramos
acusar o hacer la imputación por él
de feminicidio ya que su actuar demostró
una indiferencia un desprecio una
insensibilidad y eso es una aversión a
la mujer es misoginia este hecho generó
una ola de indignación en redes sociales
desde donde se organizaron
manifestaciones en mexico y en el
salvador a través del numeral justicia
para victoria y en plataformas como
twitter ciudadanos políticos
organizaciones defensoras de derechos
humanos y hasta los medios de
comunicación de ambos países se sumaron
al llamado para que este caso no se
quede en la impunidad retratos de
victoria elaborados por ilustradores hoy
inundan internet también se denuncia
racismo xenofobia e incluso clasismo
france24 consultó a erika guevara rosas
directora para las américas de la
organización amnistía internacional
quien advirtió que el de victoria no es
un caso aislado es un hecho en el que se
conectan lamentablemente en muchas
tragedias que pasan en méxico un país
que atraviesa desde hace muchos años una
profunda crisis en materia de derechos
humanos en el caso de victoria atraviesa
ya que viven las personas migrantes y
refugiadas la violencia que enfrentan en
los países de tránsito y en el país de
destino en este caso en méxico un país
que lamentablemente se cometen
gravísimas violaciones en contra de
personas que están buscando la
protección desde masacres por otro lado
se también el caso de victoria es un
reflejo de la alarmante violencia de
género violencia contra las mujeres en
méjico un país en donde se calcula que
entre 10 y 2 mujeres son asesinadas cada
día en donde las autoridades
lamentablemente han fallado el poder por
respuestas efectivas y adecuadas ante la
pandemia de la violencia de género que
se vive en el país es el caso de
victoria género particularmente la
indignación de los movimientos
feministas que impulsaron una vez más
campañas como ni una más ni una menos
que rechaza la violencia contra las
mujeres y el feminicidio con el numeral
mexico feminicida en internet los
colectivos arremetieron contra el
gobierno de andrés manuel lópez obrador
lo acusaron de proteger más a la
propiedad pública y cuestionaron su
falta
acción para frenar la violencia
sistemática esta vez victoria falleció a
manos de la fuerza pública un informe de
2019 de la comisión económica para
américa latina y el caribe demostró que
después de brasil méxico tenía el mayor
número de mujeres asesinadas por razones
de género mientras que honduras y el
salvador tienen la tasa más alta por
cada 100.000 mujeres en este caso que se
ha comparado con el del afroamericano
georges lloyd ha vuelto a poner sobre la
mesa denuncias sobre el excesivo uso de
la fuerza por parte de quienes deben
garantizar la seguridad bajo el numeral
la policía no me cuida a los usuarios
cuestionan qué pasa con los casos que no
quedan grabados advierten también que
esto no habría sucedido con turistas
blancos y que este episodio podría
volver a suceder ya que el sistema
policial sigue igual cuando se dice que
el caso de victoria no es un caso
aislado es precisamente porque se
combina con jugar todas estas
situaciones en un contexto de impunidad
y en un contexto donde lamentablemente
el uso excesivo de la fuerza por parte
de las autoridades policiales y
militares es una constante porque no
se accede a la justicia en estos casos
las últimas grandes protestas contra la
brutalidad policial en mexico se dieron
en junio del año pasado cuando el joven
giovanni lópez murió bajo custodia de la
policía tras ser arrestado por
presuntamente
a causa de un trauma cráneoencefálico su
familia encontró que tenía un disparo en
la pierna y las lesiones en su cuerpo
sugieren que fue víctima de tortura la
última encuesta del instituto nacional
de estadísticas y geografía hecha en
2016 a la población carcelaria encontró
que el 63.8 por ciento de los
encuestados sufrió algún tipo de
agresión física en el momento de su
arresto y el 75 puntos 6 por ciento
algún tipo de violencia psicológica
veamos ahora como registraron este hecho
los principales medios de comunicación
de méxico y el salvador empezamos con
los salvadoreños el diario el mundo dice
que victoria escapó de la violencia de
género en el salvador para morir en
manos de policías mexicanos la prensa
gráfica titula no murió la mataron el
caso de victoria ha retumbado alrededor
del mundo mientras tanto en mexico el
diario 'el universal' dice george floyd
y victoria salazar cronología y
similitudes de ambos casos y el
periódico milenio titula con el
testimonio de los pobladores de la
ciudad de tulum que dicen que la
brutalidad policial es una cosa de todos
los días
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quieres repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www punto
4 punto com
[Música]